un nuevo día de represión sangrienta con
el fin de dispersar a las muchedumbres
la policía ha adoptado tácticas cada vez
más agresivas como disparar con balas
reales por lo tanto entre disparos y
gases lacrimógenos centenares de
manifestantes volvieron a recorrer las
calles de rangún y de varias ciudades de
mianmar en 'kale habrían hecho ya cinco
heridos este martes el domingo fue el
día más mortífero desde el golpe de
estado con 18 muertos
eeuu advirtió este lunes a los
gobernantes militares de mianmar que
tomarían más medidas si las fuerzas de
seguridad del país siguen matando a
personas desarmadas y atacando a
periodistas y activistas externos y los
militares birmanos continúan por este
camino si los militares birmanos se
niegan a restaurar el gobierno
democráticamente elegido y a césar esta
abominable violencia contra
manifestantes pacíficos habrá medidas
adicionales por parte de eeuu una
posición que no apoya singapur el primer
ministro de la potencia regional declaró
en una entrevista con la bbc que las
sanciones sólo perjudican a la población
antes de nuevamente exigir la liberación
de la líder birmana and sanssouci este
martes los ministros de asuntos
exteriores de los países miembros de la
asociación de naciones del sudeste
asiático asean se preparan para mantener
conversaciones con la junta
en un intento de encontrar una salida
pacífica a la crisis
[Aplausos]